dieser Fall hat die Familie des
Schlagerstars Stefan Ross für immer
verändert Privatdetektiv Gottfried oh
erschießt moscousine Helga und ihre
Mutter Ingrid heute wird das Urteil
gegen den Doppelmörder in Salzburg
erwartet Bild hat diesen grausamen Fall
noch einmal zusammengefasst
es ist ein Albtraum für die Familie von
Stefan mroß Privatdetektiv Gottfried o
erschoss in der Nacht von fünften auf 6
mai 2021 Helga B die Cousine von
TV-Moderator Stefan mroß weil sie seine
Zudringlichkeiten ablehnte als Ingrid B
die Tante von Mross ihrer Tochter in
deren Haus in Wals in Österreich zu
Hilfe eilte wurde auch sie mit mehreren
Schüssen aus einer Glock 27 eiskalt
hingerichtet jetzt beginnt der Prozess
gegen Gottfried o vor dem Landesgericht
Salzburg die Überraschung laut der
Anklageschrift die Bild vorliegt muss
sich der brutale Stalker auch wegen
zahlreicher weiterer Verbrechen
verantworten die Staatsanwaltschaft
wirft ihm neben zweifachen Mord auch
einen versuchten Mord vor angeklagt ist
der Detektiv zudem wegen
Körperverletzung gefährlicher Drohung
fahrlässiger Körperverletzung
Tierquälerei Betrügereien in mehreren
Fällen Besitz von verbotenen Waffen
sowie Stalking Gottfried o hatte sein
späteres Opfer Helga B beharrlich
verfolgt laut Polizeibericht der
ebenfalls Bild vorliegt hatte der
jüngere Bruder des Opfers in den Monaten
vor der Tat mehrfach die Polizei um
Hilfe gebeten vergeblich laut einem
psychiatrischen Gutachten war Gottfried
o von dem roscousine besessen er sprach
von ihr als Frau seines Lebens dabei
bestand Kontakt nur von dezember 2020
bis Januar 2021 der Arzt attestiert im
Doppelmörder eine kombinierte
Persönlichkeitsstörung mit emotional
instabilen dissozialen und narzisstisch
statistischen Anteilen mit seiner Tat
hat Gottfried o das Glück der
mossfamilie für immer zerstört
[Musik]
zugeschaltet ist uns jetzt BILD-Reporter
York völkerling Jörg du begleitest den
Prozess seit Beginn an wie hat sich der
Angeklagte präsentiert
er fährt ganz klar eine emotionale
Schiene die Richterin hat ihm
vorgeworfen er soll mal seine
Mitleidsmasche rauskommen er soll mal
aufhören sich ständig selbst zum Opfer
zu machen er habe immer noch immer in
den Vorteil er könne über seine
Situation nachdenken seine beiden Opfer
könnten das nicht mehr er hat ja gesagt
er hatte Helga B unendlich geliebt und
die Richterin hat das dann abgetan als
Romeo und Julia für arme was er da den
Leuten verkaufen wolle das wahre Gesicht
kam ein bisschen zum tragen als gestern
hier im Landesgericht Salzburg der
Notruf kurz nach der Tat abgespielt
wurde da hat sich der Täter Gottfried
ober der Polizei gemeldet und hat
wirklich emotional vom Leder gezogen die
missguns der Familie beklagt ihm
gegenüber ständig hätte man ihm
vorgeworfen er sei nur hinter dem
Vermögen der Familie her dabei müsste
doch der Bruder von Helga B Robert
oberstraft werden und da fiel ein
bisschen die Maske und man hat einfach
auch gemerkt dass einfach diese diese
Mitleidsmasche die er da den
Geschworenen vorspielen will nicht
wirklich verfängt
Jörg der Prozess hat erst vor ein paar
Tagen begonnen heute soll bereits das
Urteil gefällt werden warum geht es so
schnell und welches Ergebnis erwartest
du
für österreichische Verhältnisse ist das
nicht mal schnell normalerweise wird ein
schwunggerichtsverfahren hier an einem
Tag abgehandelt aber durch die Masse der
Vorwürfe vor Mord versuchter Mord
Körperverletzung Tierquälerei dauert das
jetzt doch drei Tage ab 8.30 werden hier
am Landesgericht die Plädoyers gehalten
danach werden den Geschworenen Fragen
gestellt ob sie den Angeklagten wegen
Modus für schuldig befinden und dann
wird gegen Mittag hier das Urteil
erwartet es soll wahrscheinlich wirklich
die Frage stellen entweder 20 Jahre
Einweisung in einer Anstalt für geistig
ab Norm Rechtsbrecher oder lebenslange
Haft mit 20 Jahren wäre Gottfried oh
hier schon relativ gut bedient
vielen Dank Jörg völkerling du hältst
uns aus Salzburg weiter auf dem
Laufenden wie das Ergebnis wie das
Urteil heute ausfällt vielen Dank
[Musik]